he taught America the secret language of
Wall Street who can forget the human
piranha blowing up a client board the
title that everyone on the streets have
had to hack big swinging will you know
the rest in 1985
Michael Lewis was living in London with
his art history degree when a chance
meeting led him to a job at Salomon
Brothers he quickly became the
highest-paid member of his training
class Lewis turned that experience into
liars poker a best-selling look at the
absurdities of life on Wall Street he
explained how inexperienced
20-somethings sold millions of dollars
worth of bonds of doubtful quality how
traders engaged in feeding frenzies
gorging themselves on junk later
Lewis examined Silicon Valley's quest
for innovation in the new new thing he
uncovered the unlikely winners who made
a fortune in the subprime mortgage
meltdown that was the big short and he
turned the financial crisis into a
global travel aah with boomerang
two times now Lewis has made detours
into the world of sports
Moneyball kindled the debate in baseball
that continues to this day
and the blindside was a story of a
wealthy white family that adopted a
black teenage football player
both books were turned into hit movies